[Music]
what's this why it's the paperwork to
separate you two huh it's really
incredible I could actually see the end
of your friendship
George do something put the pen down mr.
crup or will hypnotize you when I snap
my fingers you will obey our every
command come sidekick we gotta stop him
why thank you vehicle person yeah what's
Robbie you'll get him what is happening
right now
I don't know let's try and leave and see
what happens
wow that's an expensive door mm-hmm from
the studio that brought you Shrek Kung
Fu Panda and Madagascar hi I'm George
beard I miss my best friend Harold
Hutchins we just make comics and try to
make each other laugh and this old guy
is mr. crup George oh he's the worst
principal in the world ever since you
attended this school you've been
responsible for one prank after another
some of those must have been really hard
to pull off like that tiger or that tag
it was crazy
ah I told you I could get you one day
I'm going to have you to place its SAP
rigs grasses we're going to annihilate
the friendship don't you do something
put the ping down mr. crup or will
hypnotize you snap my fingers you will
obey our every command honestly then
think that what happened this summer
come sidekick we gotta stop him why why
thank you vehicle person oh yeah who's
robbing you'll get him their greatest
creation Captain Underpants you can't
actually fly I take to the sky like an
awesome wow he is super dumb tivities
now their biggest problem stand out you
monster
[Music]
based on the worldwide phenomenon higher
Claire
I'm the cournot teacher not some scary
guy with a secret evil agenda guys I
don't got this yeah totally he's got it
Kevin Hart EDL's Thomas Middleditch Nick
Kroll when it's cut all together like
that you really get a sense of the scope
DreamWorks Captain Underpants
pour so you're trapped in some sort of
invisible box like prison is it okay
that I'm kind of loving this yet enough
I will said you breathe Oh
Mosley yet
[Music]
everyone on the beach is talking about
you guys this is Victoria Leeds the new
owner of the Huntley